اذا مشاهدينا بحسب العواجل اكثر من 5000
قتيل حتى الان جراء الزلزال الامكان في
سوريا وتركيا والتقسيم ياتي كالاتي في
سوريا وفقا لاحدث الارقام المعلنه خلف
الزلزال 1621 قتيل بينما تتعثر عمليات
الاغاثه طبعا بسبب نقص المعدات ننتقل الان
الى تركيا حيث خلف الزلزال
3549 قتيل واكثر من 22 الف مصاب فضلا عن
تدمير اكثر من 5000 مبنى كانت تركيا شهدت
صباح هذا اليوم ايضا نهز ارتداديه جديده
بقوه 5.6 درجه وفق المركز الاوروبي لرصد
الزلازل المركز قال ان الهزه سجلت على عمق
كيلومترين من جهته كشف نائب الرئيس التركي
فؤاد اوكتاي ان تركيا شهدت خلال 24 ساعه
الماضيه 3
21 هز ارتداديه نائب الرئيس التركي اوضح
ان الظروف الجويه القاسيه تجعل مهمه ايصال
المساعدات للمناطق المنكوبه صعبه جدا
[موسيقى]
هذا وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
قال ان زلزال الذي ضرب البلاد يعد من اكبر
الكوارث الطبيعيه في التاريخ مؤكدا ان
الدمار في المناطق المتضرره يتسبب في
اعاقه عمليات الانقاذ اردوغان اعلن ايضا
حاله طوارئ في المناطق المتضرره لمده
ثلاثه اشهر
هذا الزلزال يعد من اكبر الكوارث الطبيعيه
في التاريخ ومختلف القوى الامنيه
والعسكريه تشارك في عمليات الانقاذ لكن
الدمار في المناطق المتضرره يتسبب في
اعاقه هذه العمليات خصصنا اكثر من خمسه
مليارات دولار لعمليات الانقاذ وندعو كل
الدول لمساعدتنا بالمعدات اللازمه بغض
النظر عن الوضع السياسي وهناك 70 دوله
عرضت المساعده في البحث والانقاذ كذلك
هناك طائرات مسيره في عمليات الانقاذ وتم
انشاء 54 الف موقع للايواء في مناطق
الزلزال وهناك خطه لفتح فنادق انطاليا
امام المتضررين ونعلن حاله الطوارئ في
المناطق المتضرره التي ستستمر لمده ثلاثه
اشهر كما ان هناك 10 مدن اعلنت كمناطق
كوارث
المزيد معنا من القامش عبر سكايب مراسل
العربيه جمعه عكاش ومعنا من اسطنبول مفرد
العربيه غسان ابو لوز ابدا معك غسان اخر
المعلومات تفضل
بالفعل ميسون يعني اخر الحصيله التي اعلن
عنها الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وصلت
الى
3,549 قتيلا واكثر من 22 الف مصاب حتى هذه
اللحظه كما اعلن عن اجلاء
يعني انقاذ ما يزيد عن 8000 شخص من تحت
الانقاذ وما زالت عمليات المساعده
والانقاذ والاغاثه مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
وهذه الساعات وستاخذ وقتا طويلا وتوقع
الرئيس اردوغان خلال كلمه له قبل ساعات
بان يرتفع هذا العدد بشكل كبير هناك
مساحات واسعه تعرضت الى اضرار كبيره نتيجه
هذا الزلزال الكبير والتي وصفها بكارثه
غير مسبوقه الرئيس التركي وهذه النقطه
الرئيسيه فيما يتعلق بازدياد الاعداد
تصريحات الرئيس التركي كانت قبل اكثر من
ساعه ولكن العداد عداد
الضحايا لا زال على حاله ماذا يقول لنا
ذلك
بطبيعه الحال ميسون عن العمليات الانقاذ
والاغاثه مستمره وبالتالي هناك يعني
تحديثات مستمره وهناك يعني اعلان يتم يعني
من جانب السلطات التركيه حول هذه الاعداد
وهناك احاطات اعلاميه تقدمها السلطات
التركيه كل خلال ساعات يعني في كل فتره
معينه وربما خلال ساعات المقبله يكون هناك
هناك احاطات اعلاميه جديده من قبل السلطات
التركيه
وهيئه الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه
ويكون هناك اعداد اكبر من القتل ننتظر هذه
الاحاطات لكن بطبيعه الحال حجم الكارثه
وحجم الزلزال الكبير الذي ضرب مناطق واسعه
في الجنوب التركي نتحدث عن احياء ميسون في
غازي عنتاب مثلا والمناطق الاخرى
يقطنها عشرات ربما اكثر من ذلك في بعض
الاحياء بعضها تعرض لدمار شبه كامل او
دمار نصفي دمار يعني كبير يحيط هذه
الاحياء ولك ان تتخيلي في مثل هذه الاحياء
الكبيره التي يقطنها هذا العدد الكبير من
السكان كيف يمكن ان يكون الاعداد في
الساعات المقبله وربما الايام المقبله
وكما لا ننسى ميسون ان الزلزال حين وقع
وضرب تلك المناطق كان فجرا وبالتالي كان
كل الناس في البيوت نظامنا ذلك ايضا مع
عاصفه الجيو وبالتالي لا يوجد احد في نعم
صحيح نيام وبالتالي لا يوجد احد في
الشوارع والكل في المباني وبالتالي
الاتحادثين عن مباني انهارت بالكامل منازل
انهارت بالكامل على رؤوس قاتنيها وهناك
ارقام رسميه تشير بان عدد المباني حتى
اللحظه المنهاره بشكل كامل هو 5700 مبنى
لكن هناك توقعات بان هذا العدد اكبر بكثير
ازاله الاحصائيات مستمره وما زالت عمليات
الانقاذ المستمره حجم الكارثه كبير جدا
اشار له كارثه غير مسبوقه ولا مثيل لها في
العالم وبالتالي ما زالت المساعدات مستمره
سواء كانت مساعدات داخليه من الجيش التركي
والحكومه التركيه وشرطه التركيه وفرق
الانقاذ التركيه 20,000 مشارك من الفرق
لانقاذ الحكوميه والاف المتطوعين وايضا
المساعدات الخارجيه التي تصل تباعا من دول
العالم الى تركيا والوضع الذي تمر فيه
تركيا بهذه الكارثه استدعى الى
مطالبه المجتمع الدولي بتقديم المساعدات
وما زالت هناك يعني فرق انقاذ دوليه تصل
تباعا الى تركيا لتوجه الى المناطق
الجنوبيه وتقديم المساعده والاغاثه
اللازمه لكن كما تشاهدين وكما تعلمين بان
الظروف الجويه وحاله الطقس السيئه جدا
يعني هي واحده من الاسباب التي تحول او
تشكل تحدي كبير امام فرق الانقاذ التركيه
في
عمليات الانقاذ ايضا هناك الاهتزازات
الارتداديه او الهزات الارتداديه التي
ضربت البلاد هناك اكثر من 300 منذ يوم امس
ضربت البلد بعد الزلزال الكبير هل لا زالت
مستمره غسان بعض المباني او عدد كبير
المباني المتصدعان حتى الان لم يعلن لكن
لم يعلن عن هزات جديده لكن السلطات قالت
انه منذ يوم امس اكثر من 300 هزه ارتداديه
وبالتالي نعم بعضها وصل الى خمس درجات على
مقياس ريختر وبالتالي هذا هذه التحديات
كبيره تواجهها السلطات هنا هناك مخاوف من
انهيار من مباني متصدعه ايضا هناك طلب من
السلطات للمدنيين بعدم العوده الى البيوت
حتى وان كانت متضرره بشكل قليل طيب ذلك
يشكل خطر على حياتهم ولا يريدون ارتفاع في
اعداد الضحايا واعداد المفقودين وهذا
يدفعنا للتساؤل الى اين عدم العوده الى
المنازل ولكن الى اين اعود اليك غسان بعد
قليل ولكن انضم الي عبر سكايب الان مراسل
العربيه الجمعه عكاش جمعه اخر المعلومات
المتوفره لديك تفضل
ميسون في البدايه عيني احدد حصيله القتلى
عدد القتلى في عموم سوريا ارتفع حتى الان
الى
1712 قتيلا في عموم سوريا
تحدثت الارقام بعد ان رفعت الدفاع المدني
في مناطق المعارضه الرقم من 804 الى 900
قتيل احصائيه وزاره الصحه السوريه لا تزال
على حالها عن 812 قناتيه بمعنى نحن نتحدث
عن احصائيه جديده العدد بلغ وفقها الى
1712 قتيل في عموم سوريا بينما اعداد
المصابين يعني اذا جمعنا العددين نحصل على
حوالي 3500 جريح ايضا في عموم سوريا وفي
معلومات عن عن حجم الاصابات وطبيعتها وان
كان العدد مرشح للارتفاع بتركيا او لا
ميسون 3500 جريح تم تسجيلهم داخل المشافي
الاساسيه ايضا النقاط الطبيه هؤلاء الذين
تم تسجيلهم بالاسم تم تقيدهم بالاسم لكن
هناك اكيد الالاف من الاصابات الاخرى
بعضهم لم يتم تسجيلهم تم يعني تلاقي
العلاج في عيادات خاصه او في عيادات
متنقله او حتى يعني بعض المصابين والجرحى
لم يتجهوا الى المشافي واقوموا يعني
مداوات انفسهم بشكل
ذاتي او حتى ربما لم تستطع المشافي يعني
استقباله فنحن نتحدث عن عدد رسمي
3500 بين مناطق المعرضه ومناطق
النظام من بين الجرحى انضم الى قوائم
الموتى اكثر من
يعني اكثر من 83 شخص في مناطق المعارضه
خاصه في مشفى عفرين
العسكري يعني عدد كبير من الجرحى فارقوا
الحياه بسبب اصاباتهم البليغه وايضا عدم
قدره الاجهزه الطبيه
لاجراء العمليات الدقيقه المطلوبه لهؤلاء
الجرحى يعني في مشفى في احد في احد مشافي
يعني عفرين المشفى العسكري كان الاطباء
يجرون عده عمليات جراحيه دقيقه لمجموعه من
الجرحى في ان واحده يعني
لعدم التفريض بحياتهم وعدم وجود غرف
للجراحه والعنايه كان يتم اجراء عمليات
جراحيه جماعيه ولكن عمليات الانقاذ لا
زالت مستمره حتى الان وهل هناك من حديث عن
امل حول ان هناك من هم لا زالوا على قيد
الحياه او لا
يعني المدينه الوحيده التي توقفت فيها او
انتهت فيها عمليات انتشال للجثث والاحياء
من تحت الانقاض هي مدينه حماكا هناك مبنى
واحد في المدينه تهدم من ثمان طوابق تم
انتشار 43 جثه فقط من هذا المبنى يعني فوج
الاطفاء او البلديه المسؤوله عن عمليات
يعني تجسس والاحياء اعلن انتهاء عمليات
هذه العمليات في مدينه اللاذقيه القريبه
لا تزال العمليات مستمره بمشاركه من من
عناصر من الجيش الروسي ومنقذين من الجزائر
ومن لبنان اضافه الى يعني يعني وحدات من
الجيش السوري ويعني الجهات الاخرى بخاص
الدفاع المدني بينما في مناطق المعارضه لا
تزال يعني العمليات مستمره وسط الصعاب جمع
خاصه ضعف الامكانيات انخفاض في مستوى
العقود في الاليات المست في هذه المناطق
المدمره ايضا نقص في يعني نقص في
الكادر الطبي وتوقف الاسعاده العمليات لا
تزال مستمره هناك ورغم هذا نشاهد من خلفك
جمعه بانه هناك بعض القيم ساعود اليك
للحديث عنها لانه اين يذهب الناس في اي
اتجاه وهل من اماكن امنه ويمكن ان تستضيف
هؤلاء اعود اليك ولكن اسمح لي ان انتقل
الى غسان للحديث حول ما تم الاعلان عنه
والمطالبه التركيه الرسميه للناس بعدم
العوده الى منازلهم غسان هل تسمعني طيب
يبدو ان هناك مشكله بالصوت نحاول العوده
اليه في سياق هذه التغطيه عود لك جمعه
لتنقل لنا المشهد من خلفك ما الذي نراه
هنا من خيام
ميسون هذه خيام قامت الاداره الذاتيه
ومنظمه الهلال الاحمر الكردي بوضعها في
ملعب انتفاضه 12 اذار تحسبا لحدوث هزات او
ارتدادات زلزاليه قد تجبر الاهالي الى
يعني
المغادرهم هنا كما ترين هي مجموع من
القيم تتدفق عليها السكان مدينه القامشلي
منذ ليله امس وبوتيره اقل هذا النهار بعد
ان شعروا بنوع من الاطمئنان والعوده الى
المنازل ليله يعني يوم امس كان هناك
اعزائي ارتداديه منتصف النهار جعلت كل
السكان في مدينه القامشليه يخرجون من
المنازل ويذهبون الى الشوارع جزء كبير ذهب
الى الى الارياف واستخدموا البيوت التي
نسميها هنا بدور العربيه المؤلفه من طابق
واحد هذه واحده
المفترضه من اصل خمسه في مدن اخرى في شمال
شرق سوريا وهي تحوطيه في حال لو حدثت يعني
هزات او ارتداد يلجا اليها
الناس يعني ضمن اجراءات الاحترازيه ماذا
عن من فقد يبدو ان غسان عاد الينا الان
دعنا ننقل الصوره من تركيا عندما تقول
السلطات غسان
تطالب الناس بعدم الذهاب والعوده الى
منازلهم ما البديل او الى اين يتجهوا اين
هو المكان الامن بالنسبه لهم
مراكز الايواء ميسون هناك مراكز ايواء تم
فتحها في تلك الولايات وفي عشر مدن تحديدا
في المدارس وفي صلاه الرياضيه
وفنادق ايضا استقبلت هؤلاء المنكوبين في
تلك المناطق ايضا هناك خيام لكن ميسون في
هذه الظروف الصعبه الجويه الصعبه هناك
تحديات تواجه السلطات ايضا تواجه
المنكوبين من المواطنين الاتراك بحاجه
ماسه وعاجله لمساعدات انسانيه وغذائيه
وايضا
لوسائل التدفئه في هذا الطقس العاصف وفي
العاصفه الثلجيه التي تتعمق يوما بعد يوم
وربما تستمر لايام طويله وبالتالي هذه
الثنائيه زلزال
والظروف الجويه شكل التحدي كبير
وصعبت من يعني جهود الانقاذ والاغاثه
وايضا من وضع المنكوبين الموجودين في
المناطق الذين يواجهون ظروفا جويه صعبه
وبالتالي بعض الناس يعني يفضلون العوده
الى بيوتهم حتى وان تعرضت لبعض الاضرار
حتى يقيون انفسهم من هذه الظروف الجويه
القاسيه جدا ميسون لكن السلطات تشدد بان
ذلك خطر كبير على حياه المواطنين تحسبا
لاي هزات ارتداديه او موجات جديده من
الهزات الارضيه وحتى يتمكنوا ايضا من
العمل يعني
العمل في هذه الظروف القاسيه لانقاذ
العالقين تحت الانقاذ وما زالت العمليات
مستمره هناك
الجيش عمل على جسر جوي لنقل المصابين الى
ولايات اخرى وتقديم العلاجات اللازمه لهم
في المستشفيات الاخرى ايضا هناك محاوله
اجلاء وعمليات اجلاء لهؤلاء المنكوبين الى
مناطق اخرى اكثر امانا
منو سمعنا الى جمعه يقول انه هناك منطقه
ونتحدث عن حمى تم وقف وانتهت عمليات
التفتيش فيها
بتركيا هناك اكثر من مدينه واكثر من موقع
نتحدث عن حوالي لا اعلم 700 موقع او ما
شابه هل توقفت العمليات في موقع دون غيره
او لا
قبل قليل تناقلت وسائل الاعلام محليه
تركيه ان العمل توقف في احدى الولايات على
ما اعتقد ولايه كلس
وقالوا بانه لا يوجد مواطنين تحت الانقاذ
يعني يبدو انهم عمليات نشل المواطنين من
تحت الانقاذ هو ان الحياه عادت الحياه
تعود الى طبيعتها شيئا فشيئا الى تركيا
شكرا لك ومن القامشري كان معنا عبر سكايب
مراسل العربيه الجمعه والذي اعلن عن
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا في سوريا الى 1712
بدانا النشره بالحديث عن 1621 شكرا جزيلا
لكما
انتشرت مقاطع مصوره بالمسيرات فوق منطقه
هاتاي التركيه والتي تعرضت للضرر الاكبر
بعد الزلزال الذي ضرب المنطقه وتسبب بمقتل
872 شخصا في الولايه بالاضافه طبعا الى
الضرر المادي الذي طال العديد من المباني
نتابع
[موسيقى]
هذا في تركيا اما في سوريا فقد اظهرت
الصور نجاح رجال الخوذ البيضاء في انقاذ
الطفل علق تحت انقاذ احد المنازل حيث
اكدوا ان الطفل تم اخراجه وهو بصحه جيده
شوي شوي على الحديد
تمام تمام الله يجزيكم يا رب
الله اكبر ما شاء الله
[موسيقى]
الضرب
الاولاد ابني
وهو المدير الاقليمي للاعلام والتواصل في
لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه اهلا بك ومن سرمدا
بشمال سوريا ينضم الينا المتطوع في منظمه
الخوذ البيضاء في راس الخليفه وفراس اسمح
لي ان ابدا بالحديث معك كونك متطوع
وتواصلت مباشره مع هذه الكارثه ليس من
السهل الحديث الان بعد كل المشاهد القاسيه
التي شاهدتها خبرنا شوي عن تجربتك
نعم مساء الخير اولا الرحمه لي الشهداء
والشفاء العاجل للمصابين والفرج عن
العالقين تحت الانقاض الوضع ما يزال كارثه
في شمال غرب سوريا حصيله الضحايا في
ارتفاع في كل دقيقه مئات المواقع فيها
دمار ومباني فوق روسيا ساكنها تحاول فرقنا
الوصول اليهم طبعا الوضع صعب وماساوي جدا
منذ قليل
على قيد الحياه
التركيز على ماذا
من قبلكم التركيز الان على انتشال
الضحايا الذين ما زالوا على قيد الحياه من
تحت الانقاب نحاول الوصول اليهم باسرع وقت
ممكن الان فرق هناك عمل في سرمدا في اثار
في جنديرسانيا في حار في ارمناز في سلقين
تعمل بكل طاقتها للوصول الى الضحايا الذين
من الممكن ان يكونوا على قيد الحياه تحاول
الوصول اليهم لاستخراجهم قبل قليل تم
انتشال الطفلين من جنديرس على قيد الحياه
ايضا انتشار طفل وطفله احدهما عقيد الحياه
في منطقه حارم الوضع صعب نوعا ما بسبب
وجود وجود
الكثافه الكبيره للمباني التي هدمت بسبب
الزلزال ايضا عدم وجود اليات يكفي الاليات
الثقيله لا تكفي لاستخراج
الضحايا من تحت الانقاض ايضا نحتاجها معا
ذاته وفرق انقاذ اخرى تساعد
الدفاع المدني للوصول اليهم حتى اللحظه
اكثر من 35 ساعه عمل اللي فرقنا بشكل
مستمر استطعنا انكشال 900 وفيه من تحت
المنقاذ ايضا
انتشال 2300 مصاب والعدد مرشح لارتفاع
يسبب وجود عوائل عديده تحت الانقاض ما
زالت تحت الانقاذ طبعا يوجد ايضا مبادرات
مدنيه من قبل المدنيه لمساعده الدفاع
المدني لكن كل هذه المدارات لا تكفي نحتاج
للجهود دوليه من قبل المنظمات الدوليه
والدول لارسال معدات ثقيله لارسال فرق
انقاذ لارسال الوقود لارسال اي دعم حتى
اللحظه لم يدخل من باب الهوى اي دعم
للدفاع المدني او باقي المنظمات
للتوجه بالسؤال للاستاذ الياس ينضم الينا
الان ليحدثنا عن
الاستجابه من قبلكم من لجنه الانقاذ
الدوليه
كيف هي واين وصلت
شكرا سيد الميس للاستضافه الوضع هو مروع
للغايه ففي لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه كنا نقوم
منذ البارحه في اجراء تقييم لمعرفه مدى
تاثر
موظفينا في الميدان اضافه الى الشركائنا
وعائلاتهم حاليا مازلنا نقوم بهذا
الفحص للكشف عن مدى الدمار ومدى تاثر
الموظفين لدينا في الارض اضافه الى اطلاق
استجابه في شمال سوريا وجنوب تركيا
لمساعده الناس الذين هم كمثل الحاجه
والذين تدروا بشكل مباشر من هذه من هذا
الزلزال هناك سيكون مساعدات بتتعلق
بالنقود بتوفير المستلزمات الاساسيه
للمنزل
والتفاصيل المساعدات التي يمكن ان تقدم
ومتى بس اسمح لي ان اسال لانه ذكرت انه في
تقييم اولي الان هل وصلتم الى بعض الارقام
التي يمكن ان تعطينا وضع العاملين لديكم
وهل باستطاعتكم باستطاعتهم حتى الان
التحرك على الارض او
للاسف موظفينا في في الميدان يواجهون
العديد من التحديات منها الشبكات الاتصال
التي هي غير مستقره والكهرباء التي تنقطع
في معظم الاوقات فكان لدينا تحديات من
ناحيه الوصول اليهم لمعرفه الاعداد
والارقام حتى الان لم ينتهي الكشف ما زال
نحاول الاتصال الى الجميع الوصول الى جميع
الموظفين فلدينا هناك اكثر
للجميع نتمنى السلامه بس انتقل لفراس
لمعرفه الاحتياجات الان ما هي فراس
الاحتياجات بشكل عام كل ما يستطيع انقاص
حياه المدنيين تحتاج فرق الدفاع المدني
السوري نحتاج لاليات ثقيله تساعد فرقنا
نحن لدينا في كل مركز اليه او اليتان لكن
هذا العدد لا يكفي من اجل
الاستجابه لجميع المواقع التي تعرضت
للتهدم نتيجه الزلزال نحتاج لاليات ثقيله
نحتاج
للمقصات نحتاج الى مناشير نحتاج لمولدات
كهرباء نحتاج لوقود لجميع اشكال الدعم نحن
نستخدم الوقود المخزن لدينا منذ شهرين حتى
اليوم لم يتم تزويدنا باي دعم في هذه
الكارثه ننتظر تواصلنا مع جميع شركائنا
تواصلنا مع الدول وننتظر وصول الدعم من
قبل من قبلهم الينا لكن اي تاخر
فيها تقديم الدعم سواء من فرق انقاذ او من
اليات ثقيله نفقد فيه المزيد من الضحايا
نحن سابق الزمن وسابق الوقت الموت ولكن
عن انه في شوارع كثيره قد تضررت ويمكن ان
تؤخر اي انتقال لاي من الاليات الى
المواقع المتضرره ولكن ابقى معي لو سمحت
في راسه ايضا الياس اريد ان اشير الى ما
تنقله لنا وكاله الاناضول الان حول ارتفاع
منسوب مياه البحر في هاتاي وبعض الشوارع
قد تعرضت كما نشاهد من خلال هذه الصور
تعرضت للغمر طبعا هذا في تبعات
للزلزال لهذا خلال يومين حتى الان وتركيا
كما كانت هناك تصريحات تعرضت لاكثر من 300
هزه ارتداديه بعد الهزات الكبرى التي
تعرضت لها تركيا وايضا هناك الوضع
كما هو ماساوي لا زال في سوريا
احسن منك
طب اذا جبت
طالعين
واعود الى ضيفي من سرمدا نتحدث مع المتطوع
في منظمه الخوذ البيضاء في راس الخليفه
وايضا معي من روما الياس ابو عطا وهو
المدير الاقليمي للاعلام والتواصل في لجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه اذا انتم لا زلتم في
مرحله التقييم تقييم وضع
الموظفين الذين على الارض وبالتالي التحرك
مدى متى يمكن ان يكون وطبيعه الدعم الذي
يمكن ان يقدم خاصه بعدما استمعت الى ما
يحتاجه المسعفون حتى الان
تمام اعتقد بان الان ما نريده حاليا
الاولويه هي التاكد من انقاذ جميع
العالقين تحت الانقاد بعد ذلك ستقوم ايضا
نجد انقاذ الدوليه في نفس الوقت بالبدء
بالاستجابه لمساعده الناس في ظل هذه
الظروف الصعبه في شمال سوريا تحدثنا نحن
سابقا عن وجود تفشي الكوليرا والطق البارد
والازمه الاقتصاديه فهناك العديد من
التحديات التي كان يواجهونها في الاصل فمع
هذا الزلزال مروع فالوضع اصبح كارثه
الغايه بالنسبه لهم بس بدي افهم استاذ
الياس على قصه التقييم الموظفين لديكم
مخاوف انه البعض منهم ام عائلاتهم تحت
الانقاض هذا ما تقوله يعني يعني انتم من
المفترض ان تساعدوا الناس يبدو انه انتم
من المنكوبين ايضا
نعم اعتقد بان جميع من كان موجودين اللي
كانوا موجودين بشمال غرب سوريا كلهم كانوا
منكوبين لانه بالفعل نحن كموظفين لا
نستطيع ان نبدا بالعمل قبل ان نتاكد من ان
الجميع موجود وسليم ويستطيع ان يبادر
بالانقاذ فنحن لدينا موظفينا ولكن لدينا
ايضا المستفيدين لدينا الذين يجب علينا ان
نتواصل معهم ونقدم لهم الرعايه ما في فرق
دعم ان كان للتواصل مع هؤلاء على الارض او
لمساعده المنكوبين الاخرين يعني ما راح
ترسلوا مجموعه مجموعه بحث
بلجنه الانقاذ الدوليه هي منظمه لا تعنى
بالبحث والانقاذ بشكل عام على الاقل
موظفين مش عم بحكي
شو اللي ممكن
نقوم حاليا بالتواصل مع الاشخاص المسؤولين
في المنطقه بالتاكيد هناك تواصل يتم بين
الموظفين للتاكد من الانقاذهم ولكن لا
استطيع ان اقول او اعلق على الموضوع من
ناحيه انه يوجد لدينا
حركه يقومون بهذه بهذه
بس في تنسيق على مستوى المنظمات الدوليه
ومعكو او لا
كل منظمه تتحرك على هواها او بما تستطيع
حاليا لم يبدا
التنسيق نقول لنقول بطريقه رسميه للتحدث
عنه فالان الجميع منظمات سواء كانت دوليه
او محليه تقوم بالكشف عن موظفين يتاكدوا
انهم
وعائلاتهم بخير وثم ايضا سيتم البدء
مباشره او حتى بنفس الاوقات بتقديم
المساعدات للتاكد من تغطيه هذه الفجوه
والحاجات التي
نتجت من خلال هذا من خلال هذه الحاله
الطارئه طيب ساعود اليك حول المساعدات
فراس اصعب الحالات التي واجهتها خلال هذه
الكارثه
فراس الخليفه هل تسمعني
طب يبدو اننا فقدنا الاتصال مع فراس
الخليفه على كل نحاول العوده اليه واعود
اليك سيد الياس للحديث عن المساعدات التي
يمكن ان تقدم وحجم هذه المساعدات اذا ما
قدمت قديه هل هي متوفره بالفعل وكم
تحتاجون حتى تستطيعوا ان تحلوا مشكله
اللوجستيات اذا ما صح التعبير
قبل فتره كان هناك موضوع مجلس الامن
والتصويت الذي فقط ساعد بتجديد معبر
الحدودي باب الهوى لمده سته اشهر فقط وهذا
طبعا ضمن انه خلال الشتاء والدرجات
الحراره بارده سيكون هناك ادخال للمساعدات
مستمره الى ان يتم انتهاء صلاحيته في شهر
تموز القادم هلا من ناحيه اللوجستيه
زملائنا على الارض يقولون بان التواصل
ساعود اليك للحديث عن التفاصيل ولكن هناك
كلمه لوزيره الداخليه وزير الداخليه
التركي نستمع اليها المتطوعين
ويسعون لانقاذ من هم تحت الانقاض لانقاذهم
احياء
يبذل يهده
ليستنقذهم وهم احياء والى جانب هذا ايضا
مع هذا كله الخدمات الاخرى كلها الغذاء
اي الخيام ومن ثم
المساكن المؤقته
والخدمات الاخرى ايضا
الكل يسعى لايصال هذه الخدمات كلها دون
نقص الى مواطنين لكن هنالك حقيقه واضحه
الى الطريق الكثير
بسبب سوء الاحوال الجويه الطريق بين
مرعشوان غازي عنتاب الطريق
قيصري هذا الطريق احيانا يستغرق من اوقات
الانتظار ما يزيد على عشره ساعه احيانا
وهذا طبعا بسبب الظروف الجويه السيئه بسبب
الظروف المناخيه لكن نحن مع كل
الزملاء ومع كل فرقنا نحن انتقلنا الى هنا
الساعه 8:30 صباحا صباحا يوم الزلزال ومنذ
ذلك الوقت نحن في مركز التنسيق وفي الساحه
مع كل زملائنا نسعى استكمال النقائص
واستنقاذ مواطنين من تحت الانقاضي
وايضا
هذه الكارثه
المنتشره في مرعشواء غيرها نبذل جهودا
كبيرا لمكافحه اضرار هذا الزجاج نحن هنا
نحتاج الى لغه بناءه
هناك حاجه لتضامن الجميع وعلى جميع ان
يشدوا سواعدهم نحن في حاجه الى شمول
والتكامل لاننا الامر الذي نواجهه وان كان
صغيرا او كبيرا
هذا
الانسان واي موضوع يدخل بشان حياه الانسان
فهو موضوع في غايه الاهميه وبالتالي في
محافظه مرعش هدم تسعه
وحتى الان 600 شخص
من هذه المحافظه دفناهم
وخلال اعمال الدفن اداره النيابه العامه
والافتاء ومديريات الامن
الادارات المحليه
والاجهزه الطبيه
قمنا بهذه الاعمال ونقوم بها بتنسيق تام
من بين هذه المؤسسات كلها بالتعرف على
هويات
اولئك الموتى ضحايا الزلزال باخذ البصمات
والتعرف عليه من قبل اقاربهم ولا زنا
نستكمل هذه الاجراءات وفي هذا الاطار ايضا
من سواء على الصعيد الداخلي
العالمي هناك ما يزيد على 2000
96 فريق بحث وانقاذ طبعا نحن اذا صورنا ان
هناك تسعه واحد واربعين مبنى هدم بالكامل
وان هناك 2000 فريق عامل نحن هذا يوضح
بشكل ايضا
وبما يقتضي ان نوضح الشعب بناء اننا
نتسابق مع زمن لانه في بعض اماكن
كوارث هناك وبحث فرق بحث وانقاذ تعمل لمده
10 ساعات وعشرين ساعه واكثر من ذلك ومستمر
كل الاعمال
وعلى صعيد المدن التابعه للمحافظه مدينه
في الثاني الثاني
هذه المدن الى كل هذه المدن نحاول ان نصل
الى كل هذه المدن طبعا ما يفرقنا عن
المحافظات الاخرى اننا في الوقت نفسه
كنا مركز الزلزال الثاني ايضا الذي كان
بقوه 7.6 في
البيسون ولا سيما في الجنوبي من المحافظه
الاول لكن نحن بعد الزلزال الثاني واجهنا
زلزال الثاني ايضا وبالتالي وجهنا الى
ذلك الجانب الشمالي من المحافظه ايضا في
البستان في الوقت نفسه هناك هطول ثلج كثيف
والظروف مناخيه صعبه
يجب ان نركز على البستان بشكل اكبر ونحن
نقوم بذلك بالفعل نوجه الفرق القادمه الى
هنا الى تلك المنطقه
وحتى الان وخصوصا في محافظه مرعش
وجهنا احد عشر الف خيمه ما يزيد على خمسه
الاف منها تم انشاؤه واكثر من ذلك خلال
حتى هذا المؤتمر الصحفي وهنا معلومه اود
ان اشارككها واياهم واياكم هنا قوات
الجندارما
الشرطه وجنودنا البواسل
تام يعملون لحفظ امن المواطنين اولا
ولمسانده البحث والانقاذ
الاخرى ثالثا
ايضا تاسيس وانشاء الخيم هم يعملون في
تكاتف تامن ويبدلون كل جهودهم في هذا
الاطار حتى الان في عموميه التركيه هناك
ثمانيه عشر الف دركي عامل في الجندرمان
وما يقارب عشره الاف شرطي
تعليمات لتجديد وتوجيهي وتوظيف احد عشر
الاف الدركي اخر ونكمل ايضا توظيف وتوجيه
افراد الشرطه للعمل في منطقه الكوارث ما
اود توضيحه هنا هو ان الدوله
تستغل كل امكاناتها وتبذل كل امكاناتها
بشكل
يتواجه هذه الكارثه التي ليس لها سابق من
حيث ظروفها من حيث شده الزلزال وتوزعها
على مناطق عده
وايضا الى جانب هذا كله
اود ان اوضح هذه النقطه بشكل خاص
لكي لا يبقى احد من مواطنين
وحده وحيدا
ان لا يبقى مواطننا على انفراد وتحقيق
التنسيق التام ايضا بالتوفيق الامن حتى
الان تم تعيين وتوظيف 31 والي محافظ
واحد وسبعين
قائم مقام متصرف اداري في هذه الاداره كما
تم توظيف وتوجيه العديد من المؤسسات في
المحافظات المجاوره
وتم سحب
الموظفين والعاملين في ادارات في
المحافظات المجاوره الى هذه المنطقه
نواجه هذه الكارثه التي تركت فينا جروحا
غائره
هنا نقطه ان اوضحها مع تمنياتي
وبعض النواقص
هنا في هذه الطاوله احيانا نكون في ظرف
يقتضي منها ان نواجه 100 مساله مختلفه في
ان واحد ونحن نواجه هذه المشكله طبعا
مواطنين الذين هم في الساحه يعيشون مشاكل
اكبر بكثير
اذا مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر من هذه
الكلمه لوزير الداخليه التركيه يتحدث فيها
عن عمليات الانقاذ ولكن ايضا نشير الى
العواجل الدفاع المدني في الشمال السوري
يحذر من ارتفاع منسوب المياه في نهر
العاصفه غربيه ادلب كنا ايضا قد شاهدنا
بعض الصور وذلك من منطقه تركيا فيها ايضا
ارتفاع لمنسوب البحر وبعض الشوارع قد غمرت
بالمياه على كل نعود الى ضيفه من روما
الياس ابو عطا المدير الاقليمي للاعلام
والتواصل في لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه وايضا
من سرمدا بشمال سوريا معنى المتطوع في
منظمه الخوذ البيضاء في راس الخليفه
اسمحوا لي ان اكمل مع الاستاذ الياس لانه
بدا المؤتمر الصحفي في وقت كان يتحدث فيها
عن المعابر وهذه نقطه جدا مهمه بهمنا نعرف
طبيعه وضع المعابر الان وخاصه المعبر
العامل الان للنقل المساعدات
الانسانيه طبعا لجنه الانقاذ كانت داعمه
لفتح هذا المعبر بعد ان كان هناك خلاف
عليه هو تمديد العمل به كيف يعمل هذا
المعبر الان وبالمقابل هل من حاجه الى
معابر اخرى او هل من مطالب لذلك وتحرك
تفضل سيدي الياس
حاليا ما حسب ما سمعنا من التقارير فهو
مبارح او البارحه كان المعبر غير فعال فلم
يكن هناك اي ادخال للمساعدات من تركيا الى
شمال سوريا هذا طبعا اكيد صعب الوضع على
على العمال الاثاثه وعلى الناس الموجودين
اللي كانوا بيتوقعوا انه يستلموا هاي
المساعدات احنا عم نحكي عن اكثر من
مليونين و500 الف شخص بحاجه او بعتمدوا
على هاي المساعدات اللي بتدخل عبر معبر
باب الهوى بشمال غرب سوريا دعواتنا دائما
هي موجوده حاليا خصوصا اذا نحكي هلا عن
ازمه او نقول الزلزال اللي عم بيصير او
الزلازل اللي ضربت حاليا المعابر هي اشي
اساسي ومهم لحتى نتاكد انه هناك في
استمرار لتدفق المساعدات للناس لحتى يقدر
يتم الاستجابه لهاي الاحتياجات
بالاحتياجات هي زادت بزياده اكثر موجوده
صحيح لما نقول هناك اكثر من 4 مليون شخص
4 مليون شخص ساكنين او يعيشون بشمال غرب
سوريا فمع الزلزال ومع الاحتياجات اللي
كانت في الاصل موجوده سواء قل من ناحيه
اقتصاد متدهور او من ناحيه خدمات صحيه غير
كافيه او من ناحيه الحصول على الوقود
للتدفئه وغيره مع الزلزال صار عنا هناك
العديد من الناس الماسي والحاجات
والاحتياجات من روما الياس ابو عطا المدير
الاقليمي للاعلام والتواصل في لجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه شكرا لك ولكن اعود الى
ضيفه من سرمدا المتطوع في منظمه الخوذ
البيضاء اخيرا قبل ان ينقطع الاتصال كنت
قد سالتك عن اصعب
المشاهد بالنسبه لك وبالمقابل الى اي حد
يتفاعل من هم تحت الانقاض مع تعليماتكم هل
تستطيعون الهائهم حتى تستطيعوا انتشالهم
ما الذي يحدث
نعم صراحه جميع المواقف مؤلمه وصعبه التي
نواجهها اليوم وهو البارحه
اصعب موقف عندما يقوم اطفال او رجال او
نساء في النداء من تحت الانقاض ويكون هناك
مسافه بعيده للوصول اليهم نعم كل من
نستطيع ان نتواصل معه سواء عن طريق الصوت
او عن طريق
ادوات اخرى مثل الانبوب
عن طريق النداء عليه يكون هناك
هدوء ننصح بالهدوء بالانتظار ريثما تصل
فرقنا اليه نعمل بكافه الجهود لدينا لكي
نصل اليهم باسرع وقت عندما نقوم باستخراج
حد
الضحايا على قيد الحياه تكون هناك فرحه
باننا
قعدنا
وانتشلنا واعدنا الحياه لاحد الناجين
وعندما نستخرج وفيات تكون هناك حاله من
البؤس والخوف من عدم القدره على انتشال
ضحايا اخرين نعمل بسرعه كبيره والسرعه هي
اهم شيء في انتشار الضحايا من تحت الانقاذ
التي يواجهها ان هناك خوف كبير على
انتشاله هؤلاء الضحايا باسرع وقت ممكن من
اجل مساعدتهم لكي يبقى على قيد الحياه
سرمدا بشمال لسوريا كان معنى المتطوع في
منظمه الاخوه البيضاء في راس الخليفه شكرا
جزيلا لك ونتمنى لك السلامه شكرا
[موسيقى]
شددت وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا
على ضروره ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى
المناطق المنكوبه اثر الزلزال في سوريا
وممارسه الضغط على النظام السوري للتعاون
مع الجهات الدوليه طبعا بهدف اغاثه
المنكوبين نتابع
في ظل الوضع الرهيب ومع ازدياد اعداد
الضحايا في كل دقيقه والاعداد غير
المعقوله للاشخاص المفقودين من الضروري ان
تصل المساعدات الانسانيه وينطبق هذا على
شمال غربي سوريا ايضا لان وضع الامدادات
والمساعدات غير جيد لذلك يجب على جميع
الجهات الدوليه بما في ذلك روسيا ان
تستخدم نفوذها على النظام السوري لضمان
وصول المساعدات الانسانيه للضحايا وتجنب
العواق الاضافيه
ومن الحدود التركيه السوريه معنى الصحفي
ابراهيم الادلبي اهلا بك ابراهيم طبعا
بدانا النشره ب 1621
قتيل في سوريا ارتفع العدد الى 1712
وانتهى حتى هذه اللحظه او قبل دقائق 1970
المعلومات لديك
970 من بينهم 900 شخص فقط شمال غرب سوريا
بين ادلب
وحلب هذه المنطقه التي نالت نصيبها الاكبر
من الدمار بسبب قربها من مركز الزلزال
الاول والثاني ضمن الاراضي التركيه عمليات
البحث او الانتشار كما تفضل لديكم من
سرمدا ما تزال مستمره بحثا عن الامل وعن
الناجين تحت الانقاذ كنت اتحدث كنت اتحدث
في مقطع اليوم عن مشكله قد تستمر وتواجه
المدنيين وهي البقاء في العراء هناك ما
يزال عشرات الالاف من المدنيين المنتشرين
في العراء بظروف جويه قاسيه جدا مع
استمرار العاصفه المطريه حتى هذه اللحظه
اضافه الى ذلك ماده المحروقات التي تشغل
الاليات وايضا المركبات التي تتواجد على
الطرق ما بين القرى والبلدات والتي تحتوي
والتي تحوي داخلها عدد كبير من المدنيين
الذين
اتجهوا من التجمعات السكنيه الى خارجها
بحثا عن الامان في ظل ظروف جويه قاسيه
ماده الديزل تكات تنفذ من هذه الاليات مع
صعوبه التامين ماده الديزل في هذه الظروف
الجويه القاسيه للاسف هناك بعض من
المدنيين ممن عاد باتجاه مراكز القرى
والبلدات لانه وصل الى مرحله لا اقول
مرحله العجز والياس ولكن يبدو انه يفضل ان
يكون بين ركام الحجاره
لا خيارات طبعا ذكرت الاحوال الجويه كان
في انباء تتحدث عن ارتفاع منسوب المياه في
نهر العاصي ماذا نتوقع
نعم هناك هناك ان بعد تتحدث عن ارتفاع
المنسوب في نهر العاصي وايضا هناك هواجز
وتخوفات من السد ميدان كبير في حلب هذا
السد الذي او بحيره ميدانكي التي تحتوي
على كميات هائله من المياه في حال حدث
للسد اي تصدع او تشقق من ردات اهتزازيه
سيكون هناك كارثه اخرى برفقه الكوارث التي
اصبحت لا تعد ولا تحصى في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا هناك مناشده من
الابتعاد عن ارتفاع فانها خوفه من تخوفا
من زياد منسوب النهر وارتفاع يغمر هناك
الحدود التركيه السوريه الصحفي ابراهيم
الادلبي شكرا جزيلا لك ونشير الى العاجل
الاداره السوريه لمعبر باب الهوى المعبر
ليس مغلقا امام الحركه الانسانيه
والاغاثيه على كل الناس ان ندخل في
التفاصيل حول هذه المعلومات وطبيعه
المساعدات التي تصل والتي استطاعت ان تدخل
الى الجانب السوري في ظل الازمه
الانسانيه التي تابعناها النشره مستمره في
هذه التغطيه مشاهدينا ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البابا هون لا تخافي
عمو
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله
بسم الله
الله اكبر ما شاء الله